and our other top story here at six
o'clock restaurants around the valley
can now start serving food at
countertops and bar tops once again
this comes after governor steve sisilak
eased restrictions for bar service but
there are some new guidelines joe
moeller is live outside of southeast
valley eatery
with more on what those are joe
owners and managers at restaurants
across the valley including table 34
here in the southeast valley are excited
to be able to resume service at
countertops and bar tops but if you do
plan to head to a restaurant to sit at
one of those counters it will be a
little different
wonderful step in the right direction
table 34 executive chef wes kendrick
busted out the bar stools early
wednesday for service once again
i have a number of guests who just
prefer to dine at the bar last week
governor
syslock announced restaurants can resume
service for food at bars and counters
kendrick says this will bring some of
his regulars back single person
we have diminished you know capacity now
so they feel a little guilty about
taking up a table
a big amount of valley restaurants have
gaming consoles at the counters
service at those is still not allowed
food service at bars must be done from
outside the bar something that some say
requires more work and is also requiring
more tough decisions
it's too difficult jonathan fine is the
operator of parkway tavern on flamingo
and 215
in addition to several other bars and
restaurants around the valley you know
150 bartenders
and our managers just can't regulate
that someone's not taking an order for a
beer
and handing it over the bar they have to
physically walk around it
so we're leaving our bar tops closed for
now he says despite being busy
revenue is still down due to limited
capacity he hopes more restrictions will
be lifted soon
so not only are we at 50 capacity with
the seating
we can't allow people to stand up and
walk around and
which is probably 40 to 50 percent of
our of our nighttime business our happy
hour business
now back out here live restaurants like
table 34 here they're
countertops they do have to space out
those bar stools so
at this location for example they only
have three partials there but they say
it's better
than nothing reporting live in the
southeast valley joe moeller 8 news now